I want us to not sit here and act like
we had a funeral on the schedule George
Floyd should not be among the deceased
he did not die of common health
conditions he died of a common American
criminal justice malfunction he died
because of there has not been the
corrective behavior that has taught this
country that if you commit a crime it
does not matter whether you wear blue
jeans or a blue uniform you must pay for
the crime you commit
so it is not a normal funeral it is not
a normal circumstance but it's too
common and we need to deal with it
let me ask those of you that in the
traditions of eulogies need a scriptural
reference go to Ecclesiastes 3rd chapter
first verse says to everything there is
a time and a purpose and season under
the heavens I'm going to leave the day I
saw somebody standing in front of a
church the other day wood had been
boarded up as a result of violence held
the Bible in his hand I've been
preaching since I was a little boy I
never seen anyone hold a Bible like that
but I'll leave that alone but since he
held the Bible if he's watching us today
I would like him to open that Bible
and I'd like him to read Ecclesiastes 3
- every season there's a time and a
purpose and I think that it is our job
to let the world know when we see what
is going on in the streets of this
country and in Europe around the world
that you need to know what time it is
first of all we cannot use Bibles as a
prop and for those that have agendas
that are not about justice this family
will not let you use George as a prophet
if you want to get your stuff off don't
use him let us stand for what is right
because when when I got the call from
eternity crop and usually when he calls
me is not to find out how I'm doing it's
usually because something happened that
he wants National Action Network and I
to get involved and he explained to me
what was happening with this case and I
had already heard about it in the media
and immediately I said well let me know
what you want me to do he said whatever
you need to do one of one of the things
Martin that I've always had to deal with
his critics would say all our shelter
wants is publicity well that's exactly
what I want cuz nobody calls me to keep
a secret
people call me to blow up issues that
nobody else would deal with I'm gonna
blow up man and I don't apologize for
that
because you get away too much with
hiding things funny it's talked about
y'all putting clothes in the oven to
have your clothes dried well I didn't
wear them to third world but I grew up
in third Ward I grew in Brownsville and
we had roaches now I know Kevin Hart and
some of the rich Hollywood folk here
don't know where roaches are but we had
roaches Ludacris and one thing I found
out about roaches is that if you keep
the light off if you're in the dark
a roach will pull up to your dinner
table and have a five-course meal so I
learned one of the ways to deal with
roaches is if you cut the light on I
could run them roaches and track them
down and I've spent all my life chasing
roaches all over this country
[Applause]
as soon as I talked to the family and
got the details and heard that among
George's last words was I can't breathe
for the knee on his neck I immediately
thought about air Gardiner I did the
eulogy at his funeral and I called his
mother and I said I know we're not going
out because of the coronavirus but this
is so much like Eric if we could arrange
some private way to go to Minneapolis
would you go
and she said red Mile I'm already
packing let me know Tyler Perry said
I'll give the families the plane
whatever y'all need because this is
wrong
Robert Smith said don't worry about the
funeral cause people across economic and
racial lands started calling and getting
in and we flew out here her in our last
Thursday and when I stood at that spot
reason it got to me is George
Floyd story has been the story of black
folks because ever since 401 years ago
the reason we could never be who we
wanted and dreamed to be in is you kept
your knee on our neck
we were smarter than the underfunded
schools you put us in but you had your
knee on our neck we could run
corporations and not hustle in the
street but you had your knee on our neck
we had creative skills we could do
whatever anybody else could do but we
couldn't get your knee off I'm Nick what
happened to Freud happens every day in
this country and education and health
services and in every area of American
life it's time for us to stand up in
George's name and say get your knee off
our necks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the problem no matter who you are
we thought maybe we had a complex TI
maybe it was just us but even blacks
that were broke through you kept your
knee on that neck Michael Jordan won all
of these championships and you kept
digging for mess because you've got to
put a knee on our neck weight housewives
would run home to see a black woman on
TV named Oprah Winfrey and you mess with
her cuz you just can't take your knee or
our neck man comes out of a
single-parent home educates himself and
rises up and becomes the president of
the United States and you ask him for
his bread certificate cuz you can't take
your need of our neck the reason why
we're marching all over the world is we
were like George
we couldn't breathe not because there
was something wrong with our lungs but B
you wouldn't take your knee off our neck
we don't want no favors just get up off
of us and we can be and do whatever we
can be
[Applause]
they've been protests all over the world
some have looted and done other things
and none of us in this family condones
looting or violence but the thing I want
us to be real cognizant of is there's a
difference between those calling for
peace and those calling for quiet some
of y'all don't want peace you just want
quiet you just want us to shut up and
suffer in the silence the overwhelming
majority of the people March when
breaking windows they were trying to
break barriers they weren't trying to
steal nothing they were trying to get
back to justice you stole from us
those that broke the law should pay for
whatever lordy broke but so should the
four policemen that caused this funeral
today we don't have a problem denouncing
violence mr. governor we don't have a
problem mr. mayor
denouncing looting but it seems like
some in the criminal justice system have
a problem looking at a tape and knowing
there's probable cause and it takes a
long time for you to go and do what you
see that you need to do
[Applause]
but I'm one that has been krump said -
and they're working I've been involved
in a lot but he's fights we started
around criminal justice I did speeches
and eulogies that most of the funerals
that we've had in this space in the last
couple of decades and led to marches and
did what we had to do I look at Martin a
third we went to jail together fighting
these fights like his daddy went to jail
before but I'm more hopeful today than
ever why well let me go back room
Jackson always taught me stay on your
texts come back to my texts ecclesiastic
there is a time and a season and when I
looked at this time and saw marches
where in some cases young White's
outnumbered the blacks much I know that
it's a different time and a different
season when I looked and saw people in
Germany marching for George flowing it's
a different time and a different season
when they went in front of the
parliament in London England and said
it's a different time and a different
season I come to tell you America this
is the time of building with
accountability in the criminal justice
system
Stephen years ago I went to March now I
remember
young white lady looked me right in the
face and said [ __ ] go home but when I
was here last Thursday and Miss Carr and
I was headed back to the airport I
stopped near the police station and as I
was talking to a reporter a young white
girl she didn't look no older than 11
years old she tagged my suit jacket and
I looked around and I raced myself and
she looked at me and said no justice no
peace there's a different time it's a
different season and if my Bible
carrying God in front of that boarded-up
Church if I got him to open up the Bible
I want you to remember something you
know I was late last October to an
appointment because the time changed and
I was still my watch was on the wrong
time
you know once a year time goes forward
and if you don't congresswoman oh my
move your watch you gonna find yourself
hour late not because your watch was
wrong but you had your watch on the
wrong time well I come to tell you that
are sitting in Washington talking about
militarize in the country thinking that
you can sell wolf tickets to people
who's had enough of abuse I come to tell
you you can get on the TV but you are in
the wrong time time is out for not
holding you accountable time is out for
you making excuses time is out for you
trying to stall time is out for empty
eggs and empty promises time is out for
you filibustering and trying to stall
the arm of justice this is the time we
won't stop we gonna keep going until we
change the whole system of justice our
organizations have called us a day of
mourning in a ACP Nash Urban League
Legal Defense Fund black woman's
roundtable lawyers commit all got
together said we gonna have a day of
mourning but then we go come out Tuesday
morning because that summer by experts
sherrilyn Ifill and others that know the
legal field have outlined a legal
process that we must enforce everything
from residency to dealing with police
background and not being hidden talked
to Governor Andrew Cuomo today in New
York he says we got to change 58 where
the backgrounds and stop of policemen we
need to know if they stop you they find
out everything you ever did why don't we
know when policemen have a pattern
we got to go back to consent decrees
under the Obama administration they had
put certain cities with patterns and
practice under consent decrees from
Jamaa Brian to know we was pastoring in
Baltimore there they put it under
consent decree one of the first thing
that happened in the next administration
was they stopped the consent decrees we
have specific policies that need to
happen
therefore I'm glad modern 1/3 is here
today because on August 28th the 57th
anniversary of the march on Washington
we're going back to Washington Martin
that's where your father stood in the
shadows of the Lincoln Memorial and said
I have a dream where we're going back
this August 28 to restore and recommit
that dream to stand up because just like
at one era we had to fight slavery
another era we had to fight Jim Crow
another era we dealt with voting rights
this is the era to deal with policing
and criminal justice we need to go back
to Washington and stand up black white
Latino Arab in the shadows of Lincoln
and tell them this is the time to stop
this we Martin and I talked about this
of a crime Bryant to get the faith
leaders together talk for nd wise God
about the labor leaders oh no we're
going to organize in the next couple of
months in every region not only for
March but for new process and it's gonna
be led by the Freud family it's gonna be
led by the garner family and it's gonna
be led by those families that have
suffered this and knows the pain and
knows what it is to be neglected and
it's going to be getting us ready to
vote not
who's gonna be in the White House but
the Statehouse and the City Council's
that allow these policing measures to go
on question we are going to change the
time let me say this to the family who
has shown such great grace and left real
level and balance thinking and that's
why I want them to help lead this and I
won't think one of the greatest thinkers
of our time dr. Michael Eric Dyson ivax
come and speak we need to break down cuz
y'all don't know what time it is y'all
are operating like is yesterday and the
reason y'all ate catching up to what
these protests means is cuz you didn't
turn your clock forward talking about
make America great great for who and
great win we gonna make America great
for everybody for the first time
never was great for blacks never was
great for Latino wasn't never great for
others wasn't great for women young
women had to march to get the right to
vote but lastly is the religious side I
was reading and kept thinking about how
I was a little embarrassed because when
I heard that George at this point of
suffering this brutal attack call for
his momma I said to turn the Crump I
said well I appreciate talking to his
brothers and him on the phone but I
won't talk to his mother he said his
mother passed I said his mother passed
but he was calling for his mother and I
thought about it because I was raised by
a single mother
and sometimes the only thing between us
and our conditions was our mothers
sometimes the only thing that we had
that would take danger away was our
mothers the only ones that would make
sure that food was on the table was our
mother I know why George was calling for
Mama but then as I had got that all
placed in my mind and I realized why I
was always calling and my mother died
eight years ago but I still try to talk
to her sometimes just dialing cell phone
to hear the voice mail or phone that I
never cut off I still want to reach out
to mama
but talking to Quincy last night one of
his five children
Quincy said you know I was thinking
maybe he was calling his mother because
at the point that he was dying his
mother was stretching her hands
saying come on judge I welcome you when
a wicked will cease from troubling when
a weary
will be at rest there's a place where
police don't put knees on your gorge
there's a place that prosecutors don't
drag their feet maybe mama said come on
George there's a God that still sits hot
but he looks down low and he'll make a
way out of no way this God it's still on
the throne the reason we can fight I
don't care who's in the White House
there is another house that said if
we'll fight he'll fight our battles if
we stand up he'll hold us up so as we
leave here today I say to this family I
know that years ago we told him Reb
Jackson told us keep hope alive then I
know that President Obama wrote a book
about hope but I want you to know in my
life there's times that I lost hope
things can happen like this
that a - your hope but there's something
that is sister to hope called faith
faith is the substance of things hoped
for the evidence of things unseen faith
is when you got a pile of bills and no
money but you say he will provide all of
my needs faith is when you got no
medicine in the cabinet and you're sick
in your body but you say he's a doctor
that never lost a patient and he'll
Drive tears from my eyes faith is when
your friends walk out when your loved
ones turn their back
but you say I don't believe he brought
me this far to need me now we didn't
come this far by luck we didn't come
this far by some faith we
come this far by faith leaning on the
Lord trusting in his holy world he never
he never he never failed me yet from the
outhouse to the white house we come a
long way God will God shall God will God
always hands he'll make a way for his
children
go on home George get your rest George
you changed the world George
we will keep marching George we won't
keep fighting George we don't end the
cop George we're going Foley George time
out time out time out
[Music]